♪ ♪ ♪
- Robert Lepage, nous sommes
chez Duceppe où vous allez
présenter au printemps 2023
votre projet Riopelle
pour rendre hommage
eu 100 ans. Quelle idée
avez-vous en tête?
- Mon dieu, plusieurs idées,
parce qu'on ne parle pas
de
Lui-même est un personnage
difficile à saisir. Ce n'étais
pas qu'un peintre, c'est
un sculpteur. C'est un courseur
automobile. Je veux dire, c'est
un homme qui avait plu
facettes. Donc, c'est sûr que
c'est un spectacle qui aura
plusieurs facettesmmmmmmmmmmmmme
on a décidé de parler de lui,one
un spectacle aussi qui serait
long. Alors, ça fait pclclclclcs
de Robert Lepage, avec plusieurs
entractes.
(rires)
- Oui, à t
- Il y a trois volets, c'est ça.
Donc, il y aura sûrement
une pause repas.
- Ahe e e e e e e e e e e e e Ô.
- Oui, malgré que ça ne durera
ptptptptpt heures comme "Les set
branches". Mais, effectivement,
ça va être un spectacle assez- t
autant qu'il y en a dansle ciels
m'arrêter.
- Dans votre ville natale,
l'Isle-aux-Grues, où a passé
la fin de sa vie,
Jean-Paul Riopelle. Évidemment
c'est une métaphore. Il est
décédé en 2002. L'avez vous déjà
- Non, je ne l'ai jamais
rencontré. En fait, J'ai
l'impression de bien le
connaître parce que ça fait
depuis tellement longtem
sur son oeuvre. Bon, évidemment,
j'ai eu le bonheonononononontrer
sa fille et j'ai rencontré
sa veuve, Huguette Vachon.
Je suis ale e e e e e e e e e es
il a vécu, tous les ateliers
où i D D D D D Donc, j'ai
l'impression de l'avoir
rencontré.- - - - - - - - - - -.
- Bien, c'est-à-dire que ça fait
quand même depuis très longtemps
que je m'i lui, mais
je n'avais pas l'occasion
vraiment de... il y a eu une
2000, de commencer à élaborer
unururururururur lui et tout ça.
Mais, c'était complexe, puis
c'était énorme. Alors,
j'ai poursuivi cet intérêt-là.
dididididididire, un moment doné
je me suis dit un jour, un jour,
un jour.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec cette pandémie, on va
de vague en vague et
toujours repousser les limites
des moyens techniques. Jus
quel point ça vous freine dans
votre élan ça? Justement d'avoir
qui finalement briment
votre création?
- Ce qui a été difficile,
surtout pour moi, pour
pour le diamant, c'est de ne pas
pouvoir
nos sources de financement sont
principalement les tournées.
pouvait pas tourner. Et aussi
d'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'inspiration. No,
on coproduit avec beaucoup
de gens à l'étranger. Moi,
d'inspiration première. Ça, ça a
été difficile, je dois l'avouer.
-
"Maître et Marguerite"
magnifique roman
avez fait une adaptation
théâtrale à Moscou.
La production a arrêté parce qut
carrément fui la Russie pour
aller se réfugier. Vous avez dit
récemment que les Russes vonterr
contre Vladimir Poutine. Vous y
croyez encore?
- Oui, bon, évidemment je ne
la seule façon... seule façon çy
ait un Brutus.
(rires)
se sacrifie. Il faut qu'il y aie
chose. C'est de l'intérieur que
ça va se régle, , , , , , , , ,,
historiquement. Mais ça, c'est
le grand paradoxe des Russes,
c'est à dire que c'est des gens
qu u u u u u u u u u u u u u u ,
un Staline et, en ce moment,
un Poutine. Et ils se font
écraser, tout ça. Et à un moment
Mais la liberté, ça vient avec
une responsabilité. Et souvent
les Russes savent pas faire avec
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les arts de la scène, c'est
e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e. Que pensezs
de ce boycott des artistes
russes, par exemple OSM qui a
Le Conseil des arts du Canadauis
ses subventions aux artistes
russes., , , , , , , , , , , , s
d'accord avec un boycott, maispe
beaucoup de ces artistes
russes-làououououououououououout
leur permettre. Mais c'est ceux
qui sont dans une situation où
ils appuient Poutine, ou encore
o o o o o o o o o o o o o o oùs
Poutine, mais ils ne peuvent pas
parler contre lui parce qu'ils
ont des familles en Russie, pui.
Alors, il faut bien comp
Il faut analyser. Je pense qu'on
ne peut pas dire: "On boycotte
faire ça. Je pense qu'il faut
regarder chaque cas.
- J'ai vu, en septembre 2019,
la reprincncncncncncncncncncncne
la rivière à Ôta". Évidemmen
j'ai adoré. C'est un spectacle
qui pourrait revivre à Québec,
b b b b b b b b b b b b b b b s
pour éventuellement venir
à Montréal, venir à Québec,
c'est dans les cartons, mais
on va jouer "Les sept branches
de la rivière Ôta", à la
Schaubühne. Là, il y a un petit
on y présente "Les sept branches
de la rivière Ôta". Puis,
la semaine suivante, on présente
- Et vous êtes modeste, o
vous remettre un prix aussi.
(rires)
Je ne suis pas supposé le
savoir, mais b
on va me remettre un prix.
- Félicitations.
- Merci. Bon voyage.
- Me
♪ ♪